Welcome back!
Before we say goodbye
we like to play a quick game of Drewth or Dare!
(audience cheering)
You can ask me to do anything
or dare me to do anything.
And today we have Kristin.
Hi Kristin.
Hi Drew. Hello
Drewth or dare?
Dare.
Okay, everybody does Drewth. Go for it.
You are such an inspiration to all women
and I love your Instagram feed.
And I dare you to take a picture with me
for your Instagram feed.
It would be my honor and my pleasure
to take a picture with you.
(audience cheering)
Before I start crying.
We're going to take a digital picture.
Kayla, would you mind taking our picture?
By the way, Kayla your outfit today is killing me.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
That was a beautiful dare.
Thank you Kristin, so much.
Well, guess what Kristin?
In a few minutes you're gonna have to check our feed
because we'll be on it together.
I love it! I love it. Thank you.
Oh, thank you for choosing to spend your time with us.
We make this show for you so take it with you.
(upbeat music)